good morning ladies and gentlemen let me
just turn the game down there I think
that might be a little loud make sure
let me know in the chat if you can hear
me if you can hear the game in the
background
before we get started
the game is not out yet it comes out
tomorrow I believe EA posted like launch
times depending on what uh uh area of
the world you are living
um so uh but what we're going to be
doing here thank you random thing in the
twitch chat really appreciate you
clarifying that for me welcome everyone
uh good to be here with you today hope
you are excited about Star Wars Jedi
Fallen order actually not full on all
that Survivor you've been excited for
fallen order now you're excited for
Survivor this game is awesome go check
out Jordan's review uh if you want to
kind of get more Nitty Gritty on what to
expect from the game this is gonna
simply be a playthrough of some of the
opening hours of the game uh people
asking how we play it uh we get review
codes we have received review codes for
decades at this point uh Outlets you
have the ability to play the game early
and uh you know review it our review was
based off of the game pre day one patch
but uh we have now had that day one
patch so what we are playing today is
going to be what you guys will be
playing tomorrow
um as you can see here I have two
options underneath my camera start new
journey start new Journey plus I've
played
through the whole game
but we have to play from the start of a
New Journey we can't go into New Game
Plus
um but yeah uh some of the questions I
just wanted to address one I saw
multiple is how many planets are there I
got to know I'm not gonna spoil for you
how many planets or
what planets there are or anything like
that I will say what depending on how
far we get into the game the main Planet
Kobo which is the one that you've seen
in all the marketing materials the one
that all the previews were set in that
planet is massive and to me it feels
like when you first enter the lands
between an Elden ring you'll see enemies
walking around at the distance you'll
see like meditation points and puzzles
and places to explore it's kind of wild
I hopefully we can get get to that uh in
these opening hours but that planet is
one that you continuously kind of return
to and explore new areas so what's
different about these two games is less
so much like cool new Mission new planet
or returning to a bunch of planets there
are multiple planets in the game that
you do go to but you often will return
to Kobo and explore a new area which is
very different from the first game and
it makes Kobo feel
it's just infinite in how much there is
to kind of see in doing it it's a little
bit uh overwhelming I will also be
posting either later today or early
tomorrow on gamespot's YouTube channel
I will be posting an X things I wish I
knew before playing the game so I've
played through the whole game there's a
bunch of stuff playing it that I wish
the game had told me or explained better
in the early hours
that video is going to dive into that so
I recommend before you jump in to
Survivor or if you've you know jumped in
in the early hours go check out that
video when it drops uh again either
latest today or early tomorrow and it
will I think help a lot of you
kind of get your bearings with some of
like its settings and
uh where you want to spend your perk
points and things like that so
there we go so yeah here we go we are
about to jump into the start of Jedi
Survivor
let's do it are you guys excited it's a
really really good freaking game you
guys are gonna love it
uh we're just gonna play on Jedi knight
uh Jedi Knight is the one I played the
whole playthrough
play through my first play through
through I didn't change my difficulty at
any point I didn't go down I didn't go
up though some tough fights where I was
almost tempted because we had to get it
done before review I was like let's just
kick it down to Padawan or whatever I
didn't do that but we're gonna stick on
Jedi Knight I think I might kick it up
to Jedi Master uh and maybe even
Grandmaster for my uh New Journey plus
but we're just gonna do Jedi night today
uh so I don't look like I don't know how
to play the game
uh yeah so here's a little taste of the
great uh accessibility settings in the
game you can turn on and off Force
interactions you can turn on and off
navigation hints uh there's a ton of
excellent little accessibility
accessibility settings and tweaks in
this game we're just gonna leave it as
it is
I'm not playing on PC this is the game
on PS5
and I won't talk over cutscenes don't
worry
enjoy
foreign
[Music]
baby
highest times in the twitch chat this
new season of Shameless looks crazy
uh there are new punchers in the game
for people asking and people saying
there are no ponchos you have jackets
shirts and pants that you can swap out
there's a lot of customization options
in the game
and for those who are looking to pick
the game up on PC uh I have heard there
are even more Tech there's there's a ton
of technical issues with the game on
Console there are even more on PC if you
have the option to play on Console I
think the safe bet at launch is going to
be picking it up on console
you see your business
there are no ponchos
that might be Pancho is like a jacket
option I have not unlocked one and I've
unlocked a ton of the cosmetics in the
my first playthrough
crater
well thanks nux thanks for the sub
Star Wars 1313 if only we got that game
I can put subtitles on for sure
I got you and also someone asked about
the accessibility
um here are all of the accessibility
settings we can go in here we can turn
the subtitles on we'll leave them at
five if you guys need them bigger
how much space does it take up on PS5
150 gigabytes
it's huge
cool uh so this is the accessibility
settings
one thing I recommend and I'm going to
go through this in my X things video
that we're posting to the channel uh in
the next like 24 hours I set my field of
view to widest there are on console
uh five settings narrowest narrower
default wider widest
um
you're going to want to you're gonna
want to set it to that because
there's just so much going on in some of
the combat uh settings but yeah as you
can see there's a ton of accessibility
settings
there's a permanent slow-mo mode
ton of stuff
I can bump up the game volume I am gonna
actually turn the music off though
EA told us we should do that while we do
our live stream because there's uh
issues with copyright claims and things
like that so we're gonna do that
one-up Invader a guy's playing a
dangerous game
that is a Jedi
um outfit that you can find
at some point in the game
how close to Obi-Wan Stadium can you get
with the new customization if you
pre-ordered the game you have all of the
parts for Obi-Wan's lightsaber and if
you get the deluxe edition you have all
the pots for Luke Skywalker's lightsaber
like it stick with the plan today we'll
be fine as long as I get paid
we're citizens you can't treat us like
this
has seen better days
was expensive
someone's gonna pay for it
[Music]
propaganda yeah I can move my
um
yeah let me move my camera if you feel
like that would be better I thought the
middle would be better once we got into
combat
um but
we can move that down watch this the
magic this is how the sausage gets made
people I'll move it down and then if you
feel like it needs to get moved up when
we're in combat you let me know
I'm not playing on PC I'm playing on PS5
as I've said before the PC version of
this game is supposedly very very
problematic and many PC players have
recommended checking it out on console
is
it
okay
further notice security patrols will
detain and incarcerate anyone who does
not comply
thank you
get over here Jedi
the rest of you will stay here
deals change not this one I come along
and we walk only you the others must
wait
for rest you gotta let him call you then
that's enough
always nice to meet a fan
foreign
is the district secure yes Senator it
better be
it is dogs are always sniffing about
Jedi is a rare Quarry these days
what else have you brought me
see that he is paid
I'm pleasure senator
oh this isn't the last time we could do
business business together
the Renegade Jedi Cal castis
you have made quite a name for yourself
sabotaging weapon steepos disrupting
supply lines flaunting
for everyone to see
failed coup
or Norse it
that was your doing wasn't it
what do you want senator
confession
you already know I've been working with
saw Guerrera
before I deliver you to the emperor you
will lead me to the remaining Jedi
[Laughter]
are you resisting I'll speak during the
gameplay I'll find out one way or
another sometimes all it takes is a
speech but in there I have other tools
at my disposal or maybe I'll just use
this
a traitor like you
and to think one day our children will
ask what is this thing
this relic of a corrupt institution
destroyed by its own arrogance
arrogance is a trap a lot of us fall
into Senator is he talking about the
Jedi or the Empire the emperor won't
mind if I deliver you to him in pieces
uh oh what
did you really think you could Capture
Me
oh classified military Intel stored in
your yacht
and she just brought it right to me
no he fixes it up randomly
that's mine
take him Alive come and get me
out of this oh and there's dismemberment
in this game on human characters
[Music]
come on bud come on buddy
ah
[Music]
at least you cauterize the wound exactly
they'll be totally fine
there you go another one
thank God I've played 40 hours already
to nail that Parry down
my first time playing this I was not
nearly as good with the Parry now it
comes to us
uh he's coming a little hot
oh really hot
[Music]
it's okay
oh these things happen yeah the music in
this game is great I just unfortunately
have been told I need to mute it that
was a closer to the Stream So when you
guys play it'll be an even better
experience
[Applause]
stop where's the Senators
you're going to be able to change
fighting styles in like two seconds you
have the Dual wields well you have the
um you have the double-sided lightsaber
kind of from the jump like next combat
situation
uh so for people asking people saying
that they haven't played fallenwater we
do have
um some uh story recap and an everything
to know on gamespot's YouTube if you
need to catch up on the story and
remember what happened in full and order
before Survivor
I can't open it you don't have anything
for it do you
so I am playing on the quality setting
if I kick it over I'll show you what the
performance setting mode looks like I
actually think it looks better in
quality
um I think you trade way too many like
visual
uh quality you're not gonna necessarily
notice it in
on the stream but in person I think that
the quality mode at 30 frames actually
looks better
um it's a cinematic game so I actually
think like the 30 frames isn't
necessarily a problem you guys let me
know which one you want want to watch me
play it in you're not gonna notice the
you're not gonna notice obviously the
visual differences because we're
streaming right but uh yeah and then
something else I want to show you is the
uh
uh fov so this is its widest setting
this is what I recommend playing the
game on you're going to be in a ton of
combat situations where you have enemies
surrounding you on catwalks firing their
guns at you having on the widest like
literally changes how easy it is to play
uh and then this is what its default
setting looks like
so as you can see like it's a it's like
a lot tighter in on Cal and then you can
also
go to a really narrow view as well
that looks exactly the same as the wider
one so I that has the default
oh I see it's a little bit more pushed
and it's not a huge difference but the
widest setting I think it makes a big
big difference
and this is on Console I'm assuming on
PC it has like a slider you know what
I'm talking about
we gotta find that yapa for the I don't
think performance mode is 60.
I don't think we're hitting 60 frames in
this game PC can't even hit 60 frames
uh minimap this is the mini map it's
very akin to the one in Fallen order one
of the cool things you can do though in
this game is if we go to accessibility
and
color profile settings you can change
the colors of literally anything in this
game which is awesome
including elements of the map
so you can actually change like the
color of the floor like the background
terrain like you can make you can make
the areas that you haven't explored yet
or need to go to like a different shade
which is really cool
um
you can change like what unlockable
doors look like so
I don't think they've fixed the mini map
design but they've made it so you can
customize it
um
to to to where like maybe makes sense
for you
there is a graphics mode on PS5 it's
what we were playing in the beginning
this is running in performance mode now
you're not gonna notice the difference
between the two other than the frame
rate on stream because of the bit rate
of the Stream
it's gonna look quality wise pretty
identical but in person it is I think a
big Graphics drop
I played the whole game in quality mode
myself when I did my first playthrough
yes you will be able to change the color
of the lightsaber blade all of the
colors you had at the end of the first
game are available to you we just simply
need to find our workbench but the
moment we find our workbench we can
change we can start changing lightsaber
stuff and we can take a look at that in
a sec I think there's actually a
workbench in this area or the next
I don't think performance mode is 60
frames a second
I think this is closer to 45.50
it is not fully the planet of Kobo is as
much of an open world it's like way more
of an open world than we had in Fallen
order but
it is not um
uh the all of the planets are not as big
as Kobo
there are yellow lightsabers
there are not new lightsaber colors from
what I can tell so all of the lightsaber
colors you could get at the end of
Fallen order are the ones you can get in
this they haven't added any
okay
so we just spent some money on us on a
skill this lunging strike ability
which is cool
hey BD let's go now I have a question
for the chat in this playthrough do you
want me to explore all the side things
and get all the Collectibles and stuff
or do you want me to just focus on
going through the the story
if you're talking about the fight that
happens later in the game
um it's fantastic and it is easily the
hardest fight in the game desert hermit
please no one ruin it for uh for anyone
in the chat
I'm probably gonna be streaming for two
hours so we're probably gonna go to 1pm
Eastern so another hour and a half
all right people are saying main story
okay story seems to be the overwhelmed
we've got side collectible Odyssey now
people have seen collectibles
oh the way I won thank you very much
I'll do a little bit here and there
let's compromise I'm not gonna go out of
my way to find everything and there's
some things on Carson you cannot do
until you return to it anyway but if I
see like a collectible or I see like a
little something that's like right there
I'll go do it but I'm not gonna go out
of my way to to show you every nook and
Granny
there's also at this point in the game
once we get to Kobo things will
definitely change there'll be a lot more
of like oh my God there's a million
things I can see and do right now on
Coruscant it is pretty pointed anyway
okay
and take a hit
don't fall behind
what you got for me BD
you gonna scan a thing thank you
oh could you not
um get white blades in full and older I
I I thought you could also you cannot
get a red blade until you beat the game
and you can use a red blade and New Game
Plus but you you can't have until then
yeah exactly you do
get an orange blade though
so you know there you go
Hollow map unlocked we definitely
already looked at that
Scout Troopers are easily the best
Stormtroopers there's not even a
question not even a question
there's the white is new okay cool yeah
you can get away you can do a white
lightsaber then I I could have sworn
that was in foreign order but if it
wasn't that is new
the red blade is dark side
um but I think they just like hey you've
already played through the story we're
going to give you the option for
roadblade they have a potty blade as
well which I guess is like numerous I
haven't checked out
so one of the things is a potty a potty
blade that's like multi-colored or
whatever
favorite Jedi honestly after this game
calcast is making a really really good
uh uh claim for my favorite Jedi
there is no black sword
there we go here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go make quick work of those
guys
and I think we're gonna find a workbench
around here
I'm gonna change it up if you go watch I
captured all the footage for our review
if you go check out that review I have a
different lightsaber color every minute
I think I've played used all of them at
that point in the game
[Music]
come on
all right
that has to be a third game
uh if any of you watch kind of funny in
their beauty Baron Courtney on there
review said while he felt
content with the game of Fallen order
and like felt like oh that's a good wrap
up to this story I agree with him when
he said after Survivor I need the next
game immediately
uh dual wield you get at the very end of
the Coruscant intro
all right
thank you Majora's pet
I've already been I've already played
for like 40-ish hours so
what took you so long
oh you know just hanging out taking in
the side oh do I do it did I say that I
was on Coruscant
I I've made a lot of Star Wars content
this week I forgot what I've said about
a lot of stuff
more coming out tomorrow
so this is bodakuna he is one of the new
characters in the games I'm telling you
this guys why make it easy for him huh
excellent excellent character one of my
favorite new Star Wars characters we've
had in a while how comes it is Robin
Knows Best
do I know if Vader is in this game or
not I can't cannot confirm or deny any
kind of cameos like that you're just
gonna have to play the game for yourself
to see
Kube and Liz are probably starving but
the boat is bricked he is bricked he's a
big beefy boy
remind me to tell you about the career
difficulty I'm playing Jedi Knight
let's not keep them waiting
work
oh yes I think you can knock down that
crate or the shot
haptic feedback and Trigger and all that
feels good not mind-blowing not not like
not like oh this is the best I still
think the best use of haptics and stuff
was
um
Astros playroom remind me to tell you
how I got it sometime
I have not played a game that has
utilized I want you to move like that my
master
as well
sounds like a good teacher to me
Stormtrooper Patrol
for us better us than the yacht yeah
nope
I forgot that I can't climb UPS slippery
slopes welcome to those Jedi Powers if
you can't go up a slip and slide
see that cable on it because this
yes the so the guy if if you uh if you
didn't see Bode was the uh this is
masquerading as like a security guard
essentially so he was the one that
turned us in
and this was a setup if that wasn't
clear
bucket heads below no going around I
think blue has to be my favorite just
like oh I mean red Sith is hot but
it is Charles from Red Dead Redemption 2
yes
does BD get new upgrades yes
it's so funny to like look at
it
might help far and how short it is
compared to like how long my health bar
is by the end of my first playthrough
trooper's coming let's get the drop on
him sure thing on your signal
so another tip I'm going to give you is
okay another another tip I'm gonna give
you is if you look in the I don't speak
binary but I hear you BD it's an effort
if you look in the bottom right hand
corner
there's an icon like Bode like a little
Bode icon that is the
um when you're playing with other
characters which honestly doesn't happen
a ton but when it does happen you have
the ability to give them commands to
attack a Target spam it spam it as much
as possible because they do a stunning
attack even if they're attacking the
person that you want them to Target hit
the spam the the targeting button
because they only do that stunning
attack
when you hit that button
so just something to remember it's
really easy to forget reading my mind
Jedi
dark save is tight but it's it's not
like I wouldn't consider the doc's April
lightsaber color because it's just the
dog saver
oh temtem has great use of the haptics
that's a bizarre game to like be a great
tactics like option
I can't modify it off the bat again the
moment we find our first workbench I
will show you all the modifications but
I guess we haven't run into one yet
all right uh there's nothing I can do
here I can rest
um I can't change my stances because I
don't have any different lightsaber
stances yet I I don't have any perks
unlocked yet either yeah let's find the
crew
a ghost town Horizon oh that is a short
cut up there so I'm not even gonna pull
the gun outside
speaking of trouble let's avoid that
Patrol agreed the needle shop enemy's
close I got your back Kyle
um one
uh who is it Skipper asking me
skip asking me which stance that I
rocked with once I unlocked the Blaster
and cross guard stances I rarely
switched for them I think they are
weapons free they those two stances give
you the best
overall package
they support each other great
the Blaster stance is really quick it
gives you that range the cross God gives
you all the the heavy hitting
yeah you change these change stances out
of save points you can only have two
stances equipped at a time
so just keep that in mind when you're
playing
oh
here's one of the new abilities an
expanded slow Mobility
trigger fingers itchy yes you get all of
the stances
through playing playing the game and you
get Blaster and cross guard relatively
early into the game
not immediately but it's you you have
them from most of the game for sure
oh a collectible I could have right
priorite shots these are used for
cosmetic uh for binding cosmetics
this way
this is the way
I'm not gonna give specifics on when you
unlock Blaster but it is
it is earliest in the game and you
unlock cross guard
um you unlock cross guard like soon
after you unlock blasted here like it's
not like a big one
[Music]
that is wild there's nothing you can do
to like get Blaster faster that is
something you can do to get cross guard
faster much like double-sided you can go
to Jack them here early in the first
game and get the cross get the
double-sided lightsaber early if you
wanted to there's something similar with
the cross guard uh it'll be in our X
things uh I wish I knew video that'll be
going up
be the latest today or tomorrow so if
you do want the cross guard
definitely tune into that video because
it'll explain how what you want to do to
get it as early as possible
are we going to stream the new Zelda
game
probably at some point will we get to
stream it early that will depend on
whether Nintendo lets us but if we can
I'm sure we will
the emperor turned the Jedi Temple into
his Palace yeah that's what the Empire
does best take something you love yeah
so the stances are just named after the
lightsaber like what lightsaber you have
so the single sided stance double side
stance dual wheeled Blaster stance cross
guard stands
I'm not going to tell you which planets
you can or cannot go to in this game
that is something I will not spoil for
you
other than the fact that we're on Carson
and I've talked about Kobo a lot but
Kobo is the one in all previous
marketing materials
oh no sorry I'm forgetting that I don't
have my four stash abilities so I am
like
I I screwed that jump up because I
thought I could force Dash to it and I
forgot that I don't have that anymore
until you impressed him
that isn't easy
I'm good at what I do can you play New
Game Plus with all your upgrades from
the start why you have to beat the game
to play New Game Plus but all of the
upgrades from
Fallen order are in the game in the
regular playthrough you know
I I am relying so heavily on my Force
Dash ability and I don't have it because
we're playing a new playthrough
there we go
we didn't spoil the complete game
yesterday with our review we literally
told you things that happened in the
first couple of hours there is so much
story left across the bridge
to to be told like you have no idea
you think we spoiled the game but it
it's literally information you learned
within the first couple hours
I'm not ignoring you I literally just
addressed what you said
Turbo Dogs
hostiles
yeah reaction acclimates you I mean
we've seen many of them kind of already
you know
this game feels like Spider-Man wait
till you get later in the game when you
get a grappling hook then it's gonna
really feel like Spider-Man
oh
some kind of rare mineral I guess
did the patches foam the fix the
performance issues not that I can tell
I haven't had any crashes since the
patch which is great I had a bunch of
crashes when I played the game before
the patch so if it's just crashes that
it fixes I mean that is big but there's
still a ton of performance issues
there you go there's that stone let's
get in there
I don't care if I can't swear on the
stream
[Music]
give me a Target
maybe I should wrap up
maybe not oh I don't have any help
[Music]
I don't think he was a fan of you either
I don't know if quality mode has Ray
tracing on Console I am not sure if it
does
find something Buddy
like I have I have zero idea I don't
think it does worker season for
construction now on console
can you repair it
uh
Cable's a bit frayed
not in bad shape should be a quick patch
job hmm
are there any game breaking bugs well
we'll talk about it sorry
yeah
hi Jackson Walker and broke open an
imperial prison camp single-handed
that one was BD
just the two of you
and some friends
what about you new guy
win this for the credits
credits never heard
but uh
I have a daughter
got it
I don't get to see her as often as I'd
like but at least I can provide for her
must be hard being away from her
she's gonna be a lot of people's
favorite new character
the Empire took her from us
sorry
taking a lot of people
it's more every day
you ever used one of those
I'll figure it out
it was a scrapper on Brock he's an
experienced voice actor someone so young
but he played Charles in Red Dead
Redemption too aren't we all
essential cables holding good I got a
feeling you're gonna need
that wasn't so hard yeah of course
you're scared all right if gabs gets
bored she might slice into imperial
comps for fun
too good Syndicate trained but got on
the wrong side of her employers
Bravo used to apply for the Republic
military that explains a lot
oh did he voice a character in bad batch
Cantina on Northside Bounty Hunter got
the drop on me twins down a mine chat
friends ever since
I don't think this is where I'm meant to
go
maybe it is
lucky there
oh I actually should probably refuel at
this meditation station because I'm out
of uh out of stuff
yeah Charles from Audi R2 is the one
that like everyone kind of knows him
from
God what a good game
what a good game Red Dead Redemption 2
is huh
and if you disagree you're wrong
I'm just messing or am I
[Music]
it depends on what today means for you
if you're in Australia Today is tomorrow
and then yes
contact
I wish I was a scout trooper well I
don't but I wish I had their Alma
I would
Rock they're on the whole time
yeah he's been in a lot he's a storied
voice actor for sure
I have we're here be careful Googling
you definitely do not want spoilers
about like his story or his character or
anything regarding that
think that was a dead end
Red Dead is one of those games that I
played
um like a bajillion hours of and never
ended up oh that's right that's what I
have to do I played a bajillion hours of
red dead and I never beat the story
uh pipe the pipe's still going on about
this they're not massive story spoilers
they happen in the opening hours of the
game
they are totally [__] game totally within
the Embargo of what we could talk about
also I didn't write the review
so
like bro
I definitely would uh
be not be not so quick to anger as
Master Yoda might say
sorry I'm a little turned around here oh
okay yep now I'm remembering where we
needed to go might be my b
okay
oh yeah there's a ton of really great
clothing options for Cal they really
addressed the uh kind of lack of
customization great customization
pipe down pipe down Drew Smith
award for common of the day
sorrow sorrow
mean bro
[Music]
good to see you oh sorrow power goes
according to plan does it hell of an
emotion to have fun with that
was the new guy doing so that bit of a
talker a good enough bite huh I'll take
it yeah slice the yard Senator can't
call for help but he's locked in pretty
tight you trying knocking
I just bet the twins of the senator had
you in their stuffed Mountain hey I want
to cut it that
hey Kyle if you die I get the Mantis
right sorry gabs not mine to give hmm so
what's the plan
go God game of the year two God of War
Senator as the military on his personal
terminal here
could give us fighting chance against
the empire Pancho is another an option
that was a cubic Blastoise
open how are we getting in
your Fella's got the yacht down jet pack
then I'll work my slicer Magic
with my lovely assistant
I'll grab a transport
be back before you know it
twins get Cal across that Gap yeah ulcer
pipe
really thought you would have left
already if you're worried about spoilers
like I'm literally playing the game
be that there are no punchers guys I'm
so sorry
I can't get through there at this point
but we're gonna go this way these guys
are gonna push this over for me
thanks twins
your eyes sharp Bravo
is
yeah yeah yeah maybe next time you'll
check for syndic attacks before you pick
a fight okay holding up just
appreciating the view what am I looking
for
I think I can handle that
gabs gave me the heads up all right
all right
all right push that out of the way can
you tell the twins to pull down the
yacht
the best things about the game is like
cow starts out feeling really powerful
already
they just kind of Ratchet up the typical
you know ratchet of the difficulty and
and the I'm always careful
the variety of enemies to kind of push
you
won't be beyond that right
for the record I loosened it up for you
nice job
for this nope
I remember this being like I don't know
maybe I'm meant to drop
I was meant to go back it was weird oh
ah here we go this is where I needed to
go Speedy when you're ready
you need to be rebooted or something
glider on the back but
he Force he fills his puncher with force
and he plays around the map there are
creatures that you can kind of hang
underneath from and glide around the map
but it isn't upon it isn't his Poncho
that would be so funny if that's how
they did it in the game he just opens up
his Poncho and then like force back
oh now I wish that that was how they did
it
finish business
give us your terminal passcode
excuse me
maybe I could change his mind
will give me access to do you have Jedi
Mind Tricks in this game which is really
sucked
what should we do trust or reward trust
the reward quick quick trust reward
which one which one trust reward trust
reward uh trust never mind trust us
we're all friends here
unlock it we're all friends here
I can trust you I will unlock the
terminal
well it made the decision for you random
thing so
good thing you want to trust
also we're not gonna reward this son of
a [__] you know what I mean he moves
blast him oh my pleasure
all right BD
see what we got
they're everywhere
[Music]
not the Breakthrough we were hoping for
years of fighting
no there's this there's not there are no
like story choices in the game what did
you expect
you're lost the Republic is dead it was
killed by politicians just like you
do you think I wanted UTA power to join
the empire
the compromises I made created a future
for my people I've been to utepo senator
they spit your name out like a curse at
least they are alive
why fight when you can't win
surrender taste bitter at first cow
but sweetens with time
free me
and we'll cut a deal
no senator
someday when your children see this
they'll know the Jedi never stopped
fighting for them
amen dude let's go huntingly naive
Skipper in the chat
I was really hoping for some Buddha
power
hands yeah and we got it coming with us
okay let's take their food to go
I'll say this I think this game does you
know that conversation he had with the
senator was super interesting you know
about the fact he's like look I don't
want to join the Empire but I had to
think about my people
and boat is like they they hate you and
he's like yeah but it's better than the
mole being dead like
the game has a ton of stuff in this
about like compromise and sacrifice and
um
all of these like story elements I think
this game does some of that stuff about
what is good what is evil the light
versus the dark I think this game does
this that better than anything in Star
Wars that I've seen before by the end of
this game you are gonna be you're gonna
feel a lot of conflict
about
how things have played out
and
characters decisions I'm so excited for
people to to play this I think people
are really really really gonna love this
story School of negotiation should I
start with first didn't you call me
sharp Chand
and yes that's the grand Inquisitor is
also in here
this this game has a lot of story things
tied that was similar with Andor for
sure
but you it stars the Jedi
lucky you Senator you've got a day with
song Herrera kill me oh my cat is
looking for attention whether you
cooperate that's a skill senator's prize
right cooperation is our time for a
quick tour of seijan's terminal I could
see if the Senators got anything else we
could use and by we you mean dirt you
can sell to make some credits you can
fight the good fight and still get yours
along the way Cal that's War maybe next
time fine but lunch is on you and the
twins are starving
we get what we need yeah
I wonder what Saul has for us next first
we gotta get this Intel top side
we got a plan for the senator
still thinking it through
we could always ask Cube and Liz to see
whether the senator can fly
you'll pay for this calcus
I've changed my mind
yeah feels good to make a difference no
they're loaded filthy rich
make the huts look clean by comparison
I bet the senator has more credits
one of the planets is pretty open world
it's way bigger than anything in the
first game but not every planet
you have been caught harboring a traitor
pastors
[Music]
time
Kobo is really open walled will probably
end the stream right as we kind of start
exploring that and you'll see it's way
way way bigger than anything you've seen
in Fallen order or or that you will see
in the rest of survival
yep no that's the end of that Senator
he's gone in the first hour hell gotta
go
come back
hell where you going
[__] it go
yeah she has a metal arm can't have a uh
kind of a Star Wars game without a
character without a robotic arm there's
a couple in this game actually I think
because in the book that's set between
Battle Scars that set between this game
and
between Fallen order in this game
um Greece loses an arm and so he has a
robotic arm in this as well later gotta
keep moving
oh these these freaking things
hunting us buddy gotta stay one step
ahead
oh no
oh damn oh there you go first death take
a shot
but this teaches us
about respawning and getting your XP
back and all that
I thought I was going to be able to
dodge okay
how are you able to play this while
reading the chat I've been streaming for
years it's it's a skill that you
cultivate all the time
oh I should probably have stopped here
stop at every meditation point you find
because you can fast travel in this game
and you're gonna want to do that because
you're gonna have to double back in some
locations you're gonna explore some
areas and hit a wall so always stop at a
meditation point
oh
[Music]
quick tip when you're playing this game
if you want to do a finisher move
there's going to be like a red dot when
they're low Health that comes over them
don't immediately hit the square
unfortunately the finished move is just
like the attack button and so often it
will just kind of continue the combo
rather than doing the finishing move so
if you see that red reticle come up over
the enemy
pause for a second
and and we'll kind of line it up and
then press square or X if you're playing
on Xbox or I don't know what the
keyboard command is but just kind of
give it a beat because the finisher
won't happen unless you kind of
like you have to kind of end the combo
and then line up the finisher
uh all of these crates are super useful
because they have
stim packs
stem canister that'll prove useful
I don't know who plays on keyboard but
there's some people out there I'm sure
robot Sushi baby
ob1 and Kenobi I was saying to this
earliest people in the chat but uh we
can't get through here at this point we
don't have the ability to do so that
Way's blocked come on we'll come back
later oh we don't have the ability to do
that either
ah just out of range
more dismemberment
I made a joke to my colleagues when I
was playing this game for the first time
and I realized that was dismemberment
um I was like it's like gonna peek
because it's a t-rated game I was like
it's like in a PG-13 movie where you get
one f word in this game each character
gets one dismemberment like he'll never
cut off like both their arms or a leg
and an arm it's like you get a leg or an
arm but you don't get any more than that
thank you
this is fun watch this
cutting up the meat the meat the meat
cubes
[Music]
performance after the Patch it's it's
hard to say it's really hard to say I
played most of the game before the patch
I haven't had any crashes since the
patch which is great but
there's still a bunch of visual hiccups
and things here and there that
definitely happen I'm hearing of the
console like a lot of the ports that for
PC that have been
um
you know a thing recently like the
console version is way more stable in
the PC version skillup lost his save
when updating to the patch
which is something they warned us would
happen when they said the day zero patch
though like it could corrupt your save
but I haven't heard of that happening on
PS5 granted just to clarify just clarify
that will that should not happen to you
because when you get the game you will
have the patch already so that is I just
want to be very clear
there should be zero risk of you losing
your save
when playing this game that was just
something for us reviewers and they were
very upfront about that being a
possibility
so just so you know
uh yes we have the ability to confuse it
can someone who remembers and Fallen
order could you do this in the first
game I don't think any good
oh you can make them fight each other
which becomes a really useful skill also
something don't forget to spam this
either
sorry buddy
like that
yes cyber demon that's a great point
there is no blood because you can call
you're cauterizing the wound immediately
Troopers
gotta be careful BD
which that would probably mean that
everyone would probably be okay
[Laughter]
like it's the bleeding out that kills
you oh I'm I'm just jumping for the sake
of jumping guys I'm sorry
all right
oh whoops
sit here
man I wish I could play like New Game
Plus and show you all the cool skills
that I unlocked there are so many moves
that I can I have on my double-sided
lightsaber that I can do that I can't do
with this playthrough
come on buddy take the shot
oh they're dead
oh let's not get started about people in
twitch chat let's not talk about the
principles uh the sequels I just can't
I just can't have Star Wars discourse
let's just enjoy the very good new Star
Wars game
oh yes of course of course I can yes I
wanted to do that when we got into
gameplay so let me just maybe if I put
maybe if I put my camera like right here
that's going to be the best Both Worlds
for people
sorry about that
yeah so you'll be able to see the stance
we'll see what's up
so I've got a new skill point something
I recommend don't feel the moment you
get a skill point you have to spend it
um I'm just gonna do it for the sake of
this but there's a lot of really great
to
um skill skills that require two skill
points that you can get early on
so I wrote even early in the game like
having them stack like I recommend it
let's go
all right Nooks lady gator
all right
good talking to you as well Knox have a
good day enjoy survival when you get
your hands on
[Music]
that was handy cow
and stuff like that
false triggers
keep that other gunship
[Music]
you failed
you failed yourself
impressive
but you're hurting bad inside kestus I
can sense no she's not dead she just got
around again oh thank you it was very
like nebulous to their deaths
and she's very much alive it makes you
so so predictable
so when she does this ability right here
what she's like holding her hand to her
head you have to use force abilities to
kind of kick her out of this
yeah and then she like does a big
lightsaber attack
affected by lightsaber hits
foreign
thank you
I'm so tired
oh
she negated my slime over that sucks
oh I've got an itchy nose my nose is
itching oh God
Nelson For The Simpsons that's funny
that is really there we go duel baby
here we go
thank you
and there you go that's how you unlock
dual stance
[Music]
very quick
it also doesn't the least amount of
damage out of anything at any single hit
me
oh yeah so this is sick if you hold
triangle
it will you'll see but it can block
basically any attack without able parry
and counter-attack without you having to
do any timing it's pretty cool
watch this
Persona so he just like he just like
floats his lightsabers and when they
attack boom bam so cool
you were a Jedi Knight
before you betrayed our order
here
your name was Asana tide
it's time to set you free
Ze
yeah
I'm okay
double-bladed duel would be wild but you
do not get that I will spoil that for
you you do not care that in this game
so yeah you can change stances so you
could have
um you know dual wielding on you know
this side double on this
you know
yeah we confirmed it confirmed
confirm's dead
only one allowed exactly
don't worry we get some excellent
villains in this game
hey I saw a lot of people online who who
were like oh man I really wish like the
ninth sister was like the boss this time
around trust me
we got something far more interesting
with this game
so something I recommend
also when you play I put all of my
points in boosting my maximum Force I
think at the beginning of the game it's
pretty stingy it gives you like very
little Force to play with like you get
two Force pushes in and then it's maxed
you will unlock uh Force increase there
are like things in the game that you can
like kind of meditate at that like
crystals and they give you more force
and health but I spent all pretty much
all of my points in the early moments
upgrading how much maximum Force I have
and I recommend doing that because you
just get a lot more to play with right
the heavy attacks are also use Force
meter as well so you know if you use a
force push and then use a heavy attack
like you have you have to wait
yeah so you can you can you can change
the the forces
so you'll see actually if we go to
stances real quick so if we do let's do
single-sided and dual wheeled right
so if we if we do single-sided
it's like that and then if we go to dual
wield he'll grab the the second half of
all off of the Hill there
very cool
all right
thank you
both Bravo are you there
let's get back to the Mantis random
thing in twitch chat says Cal is nearing
the dark side with his euphemism of
setting one free
I can't wait for you guys to play this
game that's all I'm gonna say goodbye
my old that's left I love that dude
honestly so one of the one of the fun
things in Kobo is you know they'll be
enemies just kind of Milling about that
you can fight
they have some really fun dialogue when
they're just like walking around and
don't recognize yet so I would say like
before you attack enemies like give them
a second and uh they'll
[Music]
they'll they'll drop some great
one-liners for you
is there a setting to turn off haptics
that's a great question I assume so
because
um
okay so it's not under controller
disable UI input hold trigger effect
function
let's look in accessibility if you could
turn haptics off
hmm maybe you can't
interesting
it doesn't look from a quick glance it
doesn't look like you can but there's a
lot of settings in there maybe
oh Kobo is the best planet in the game
because of how different it is from the
others it it feels I said this early in
the Stream
oh yeah let's let's do the full facility
come on baby let's go
[Music]
thank you
but Kobo is I said in the beginning but
Kobo when you and we'll probably get
there honestly
when we first get to Kobo
and
see the world it's like stepping into
the lands between an elder ring oh
whoops I missed that job my bad
like it's huge there's a ton of
different
and instead of instead of in the first
game where it was kind of like if you
had a new Mission you were kind of going
to a new planet often
a lot of the game takes place on Kobo
and it just takes place in different
parts of Kobo so there's like a forest
area there's like a volcanic area
there's a swampy area
well dual wielding in one so legit
flippy asks
is you mean double-sided oh you can't
if you're dual wielding you have both
halves
to our life
thanks for this crazy stuff and you
cannot have double-sided with Blaster oh
man the blasto stances which has a
single-sided lightsaber because it's
meant to be faster
not at will you need to you need to get
to the stingamantis like the first game
I should have they know what they signed
up for
we need to get top sign and transmit
that into soccer era this is a console
PS5
Zoo coast and twitch chat says hello
does this game Run well on PC from
everything that I've heard College PC is
going to be the worst way to play this
game at launch
you're gonna be disappointed with how it
performs
whereas on Console you can have a you
can't be as disappointed because you
didn't spend thousands of dollars on a
machine Bravo
we got OverWatch I want it all right
it is a scar and you can find out how
Kyle got that scar in the book Jedi
Battle Scars which is set in between
this game and uh Survivor you'll also
learn how Greece lost his arm
we live stream on this channel around
big game releases
I have a personal twitch Channel you
guys can actually find me uh everywhere
on the internet at Great britom like
Great Britain but Tom at the end uh I
have a twitch Channel I stream every
Sunday and Wednesday in fact if any of
you are avatar Last Airbender fans or
horror fans or anything like that on my
stream every Sunday we're doing the
Avatar Legends uh ttrpg the like
dnd-esque role-playing game we just
started that up it's a lot of fun having
a blast with that so if you're into that
definitely go check out my twitch
Channel again great britom on Twitch
and unranked podcast on youtube.com
forward slash unranked podcast unranked
is the name of my podcast if you are a
fan of content like Giant Bomb
where it's just a bunch of people
bullshitting and talking about games
like on ranked podcast was created in
that vein we've been running it for like
seven years at this point go check it
out
um but yeah I can't open that door that
is a thing we get much later in the game
so yes you will be able to return to
Carson and there's things to see and do
later that you can't see anything the
first time around
it's great dog Fisk it's the the avatar
uh tabletop RBG is fantastic
uh let's go into skills
I might play Survivor there later on
um
probably will be playing Survivor on
there late game Survivor like with all
the abilities and stuff so yeah but for
right now before the game launches we
can only stream the opening of the game
oh let's do a confusion upgrade for sure
confusion is such a useful ability
why the game's so big someone asks ah
it's a very impressive technically
impressive game and there's a lot to see
and do that's why it's so big
white game's so big
let's move
I love the like Blaster blocking dual
wield motion because it just looks like
deflatable
inflatable Tube Man
oh he took him out before I could do it
[Music]
how is he moving his wrists like that
so I actually ended up using dual
wielding the least in the game because
it doesn't have a heavy attack the heavy
attack is just the like for this Force
Parry move
oh
no problem so I always found myself
going to instinctively go to do a heavy
attack with dual wield only to find out
there is no heavy attack it's just the
floating Force Parry
take him down
that'll teach him
um I remember kind of being a little oh
I think I just need to talk to them
uh cross God and Blaster once I unlocked
those those were the two stances I
pretty much rocked through the entire
game I I think cross God is my favorite
of the three but I'm always like a heavy
weapon guy like like in Dark Souls I'm
always like get the biggest swords to
take the biggest swings so you both so
it kind of speaks more more to me it's
been a great Blaster is fantastic I you
will I I almost guarantee once you
unlock Blaster and start playing with it
it's never gonna deal
because it's the single-sided with a gun
it's so good
and it's so useful to have more work to
be done
looks like I made the cut huh
the buddy system is throughout the game
it's not utilized let's be with you
it's not utilized a ton like it's not
um see how well you fly yeah
what addition will we given to trial uh
we received the deluxe edition so
actually once we get into I really
thought there'd be a workbench on
Coruscant but there isn't but the moment
we get to a workbench I'll show you all
the different
um how are we looking lightsabers and
stuff that we can create
whatever it is comes out tomorrow for
public Adam unless you're like I said
unless you're like in Australia in which
case it's available now
uh I don't think you can customize the
Mantis you could change the color of the
maps in the first game right I don't
think that's in this I have not found it
and I've played the whole game so
oh
no
traffic looks like this Portal's under
maintenance as soon as we preached the
surface jump to light speed
gotta take the risk we've already
overstayed our welcome
also this [__] is fine enjoy
we got company
[Applause]
on my mark hit the brakes we'll drop
behind him copy that Bravo
nice work everyone
hope that's the last of them not a fan
of long goodbyes
is that what the uh these ships hold
well they called z95s that like x-wings
but they don't have the X they just have
the one thing I I had never seen this
ship before but that's so cool
is that like really skinny actually
can't shake them
hold on this hole
[Applause]
that's one way to do it learn that move
from you
there's a Rex head we're almost there
more coming in from the surface
[Applause]
foreign
writing Diagnostics while I transmit the
Intel
said
let's hope this information does some
good
we did it
the z95 is a sick
right
but it's off my table okay
well
it's as we hoped
this book is a copy from the Jedi
archive grease here
if you're gonna stop the Empire from
getting the rest
patience this war won't be won soon
or by us alone
the Galaxy is vastroid
and I have seen only a little of what it
has to offer
but one day
I will return to gothamir
and Whisper what I have learned to my
sleeping sisters
there were nothing divided
you know it's not often I break out an
old family recipe like this
what do you think
it's good
could use some more salt
too much salt is bad for you
Wonderful Grace
I'd actually pay credits for this oh
yeah hey I might start charging you Cal
all of these characters as great as they
were in full and order they are even
better
Greece Marin say they're all fantastic
in this game
like in dear to them even like way more
than I was in Fallen order even random
thing asks do we go back to death in
this game I'm not going to spoil which
planets other than Kobo which we're
about to arrive on you see in this game
but yeah
Gyro's failing
I need that
any ports nearby that won't turn Us in
for a reward
pull up the Cobo system
foreign
settle down
out in the middle of nowhere
could be a good place to lay low
if anyone knows how to fix up the Mantis
it's Grease tritus
think we can make it
we should tidy up before we visit Greece
you know how he is about mess
I'm pretty sure
yeah and bd1 gets a bunch of vision it's
not just colors now we can change like
Beady ones like build here we go
workbenches let's do it it's back on the
work all right
okay what do we got
so the hermit is the if you pre-ordered
the game you'll get the hermit
lightsaber options and clothing which
are Obi ones Rebel Heroes if you get the
deluxe edition
how many platinum how many platinum
trophies do I have all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna take a quick story here ladies
and gents super quick we'll get back to
the game in a second you guys love this
and it's a tragic tragic story
uh this tale of doth Plagueis the Wise
how many platinum trophies do I have
I have zero Platinum trophies and that
is because I'm not a Trophy Hunter
the one time I tried to get a platinum
was Spider-Man PS4
after playing the game I had like 80 of
Truth trophies right
I
the last one I needed to go get to get
the Platinum was visit Uncle Ben's grave
uh and I did
and the Platinum didn't pop
the trophy
said you've completed it but it never
gave me the Platinum
and then the PS5 upgrade came out and I
thought oh maybe this will give me the
Platinum finally
uh so I went into the PS5 upgrade and no
that didn't pop either so I have done
everything in Spider-Man 2018
to get the platinum in that game
but I don't have it
actually and that killed any desire for
me to ever try and get a platinum trophy
yeah exactly that was the Platinum Knoll
that I was going for and it
unfortunately escaped my grasp
so the one thing about like the
lightsaber and everything and like
building Luke's lightsabers you have to
do it manually which is kind of
frustrating like you can't just say like
oh give me Luke's lightsaber
um
you have to like choose all of the
pieces and then you have to choose the
paints but you can mix and match but
this is what Luke's lightsaber would
kind of look like double-sided and then
you go into so there's blades right and
you can choose the color so there's blue
green purple yellow
cyan
magenta
indigo
Orange
oh red okay to be clear
red I have unlocked because I've beaten
the game you will not have read when you
boot up the game for the first time
thank you
yeah it has Force grab for sure
there's white you have that at the
beginning of the game and then there's
party which
is it changing colors what's going on
here
oh is it just random
or is it also in between colors
sorry Anakin's lightsaber yes it can be
Anakin's
um but to so you have all the parts but
as you can see it looks kind of
different so what you need to go is into
materials and go to
um
I thought they were Deluxe paints
where are my Deluxe paints
oh there okay interesting so I think the
sheen of silver is correct
the grip we need to make black
and it doesn't look it doesn't look
black in this lighting but it is you'll
see in the game
I think the accent is electrum plated
and I think it's also a metal alloy for
this part
and then crank the Polish all the way up
you can probably crank the Polish of the
grip all the way down because it's
rubber
and then you want to change the
condition because as you can see there's
like different layers but pristine
and you can actually what's really cool
is it can go in
got a good feeling about this material
the customization in this game for like
lightsabers and stuff is
off the chain
maybe it is chromium
let's see how it handles
we're almost there let's head up to the
cockpit
yeah I'm playing on PS5 games you're so
good you potty
go potty potty time
I'm not gonna play Potty because I don't
want to get in trouble with EA
we'll keep it a blue I'm playing with
Luke's lightsaber slash Anakin's
lightsaber we'll keep it we'll keep it
to the blue
it does it does actually if you pick
purple it etches onto the side of the
lights of a pad
yeah customization in this game
light years
about what is informal feeling all over
the guy I think hey no what's up baby
no Arena longtime listener of the
unranked podcast
he'll duel the evangelizing for me that
uh that I need
We're not gonna make it to the hangar
gotta put her down
hold on PD
[Music]
f
completely fried
we won't be flying again without repairs
oh yeah jaw is everywhere okay
This Is Us
good to see you now The Outpost
I guess we finally get to see Grace's
Cantina
all right Majora's Pat all right come on
which Star Wars movie is my favorite
this one
like if you took the cut scenes from
this game it would be my favorite Star
Wars movie
uh oh let's also show off so we can
customize Cal and we have
so
you have hair options which I haven't in
this playthrough you haven't unlocked
any
um you can also change you can also give
him clean shaven you can go stubble
clean shaven there
uh there's the jackets so these are the
the rebel hero and scoundrel are Deluxe
Edition ones The Hermit is pre-order
um but yeah we can do that and you can
even change the color so the yellow is
the is the iconic one from the end of
episode four
but you can change the the kind of color
of it and like some of the design
then you have shirts
so the rebel hero one this is again the
Luke Skywalker look scoundrel being
the Han Solo one and then you have pants
and that's Cal is Luke Skywalker with
his lightsaber
it's so calm Empire Strikes Back is the
is the is the best
all nine I would say
okay so grease is on the other side of
all this
mind giving me a closer look
that is one big beast
we have our Target now let's reach it
we don't have uh uh a Return of the Jedi
black outfit as far as I
as far as I can tell what I found from
my first playthrough we just have this
outfit
that would be sick
last time I saw a lucra Hulk was braqqa
a long time ago rough
[Music]
you say now come on mantis won't repair
itself just hope Greece has the parts we
need
always remember to rest if you need to
rest don't forget to do it like I did
numerous times in my playthrough
foreign
[Music]
thank you
stay still
these don't look like any separatists I
remember at one Raiders
what has Grace gotten himself into
[Music]
foreign
oh if I missed it if I missed if I
missed anything I'm just kind of like
I'm not doing all of the side stuff that
I already did on my first playthrough
I'm just kind of get what I want to do
is get to when we get to ramble's reach
and the open world opens up and show you
guys that because it's it's pretty
exciting
nice work yeah and there's tons of
shortcuts in the game
oh
my God
another day I never eliminated
[Music]
I think it's safe to say these Droids
have new Masters
sinking
Gotta Move
okay so they explode
oh whoops right my bad that's not what I
needed it doesn't sound good
I need to rise the thing so I can make
them jump here
I'll get your thing I can't get your
thing right now I'll get it later buddy
all right there's a chest over here
yeah dual Skywalker lightsabers
there we go we can give him a short
beard a great big bushy beard
don't they see the bigger picture
negative game's great Eric clocks
you're a Droid gonna be tough I think
for something else to beat up the game
of the year for me we'll see how it does
and also like the game only gets
like the game starts out strong and it
just gets better like the by the end of
the credits
okay I needed to play the second game
yes we're putting out the uh we're gonna
be putting out a video either later this
evening or early tomorrow that explains
how to get across card early
uh we get it early because we got a
review code from EA so we've got the
review up I've already beaten the game
we just need to find a way we're just
checking out the early moment it's gonna
be a surprise to see us huh the early
moments of it right now
based on story this one like based on
every Factor this is a better game or I
think the the problem with Fallen order
is that it's whole inciting incident is
like oh Cal has something that could
allow him to oh there's another one uh
restart the Jedi Order which we know
can't happen so it's already like
there's some tension removed from that
because there's there's he can't stop
the Jedi Order he just can't do that
this game
the story
opens up a ton of possibility for where
these characters end up in the future
and like a ton of possibility
for like the future of Star Wars in
general it manages to find a way to kind
of decouple itself together by much the
overall like Cannon
in a really smart way that doesn't
actually affect the Canon that means
that you have no idea where these
characters are going to end up whereas
in Fallen order it was like well he
can't start the Jedi Order you just
can't do that so you know
huh
yeah there's some great games great
games to be played
all right we're just gonna get through
this area and then we will wrap it up
seeds there's seeds
collect let's go BD gardening
the cow is looking if if I made him uh
if I gave him a if I could give him a
brown beards or you know yeah
look at this
then yeah
am I excited is the kingdom
a thousand million dude that last
trailer was the most hype thing I've
ever seen in my life kidding me oh my
God I still watch it I like just like
you want to feel good about life you
want to feel good about the future you
just watch that okay
I actually do things go this way
oh
this is not Naboo this is Kobo this is
the maid this is the main planet in the
game it is
substantially bigger than any other
planet in Fallen order or even in the
rest of this game the other planets in
this game are very much like Fallen
order where it's it's big open paths
with kind of side paths this is an open
world
but for the ones but we'll see
I'm gonna show that the last thing I'm
going to show you is
this intro area is not indicative of the
rest of hobo
okay
oh that was a big hit
oh
that was wild
this is a PS5
do that's Tis the controls
[__] hatch watch it if you've not
seen it
I used to recall
foreign
okay so we got
is this not where I'm meant to go
maybe it is just this area I need to get
just throw that for the sake of throwing
it
I need to get into here
oh
no I'm not finding you one things right
now
I need to
oh right yes yes yes yes
please let me go we won't Prospect in
The Gorge again you hear that no do it
quality in another one down
oh well
there we go
[Music]
very nice
uh there's a mini game in here that is
it's called Hollow tactics that you
unlock later in the Cantina it was
trespassing it's very simple and a lot
of fun you get to add characters to that
to play with by scanning enemies and it
basically is kind of like what are you
taking your action figures and be like
oh if three Stormtroopers went up
against three battle droids who would
win in a battle like that's what Hollow
tactics is so make sure it'll always be
scanning enemies when it gives you the
option because it adds them to your
collection for holo tactics
[Music]
so much
commando droid
I didn't miss these oh my God I Oh I
thought he said Mando Droid
I was like what Mandalorian Droid
these guys by the way these Bedlam
readers are always hiding behind you
guys so always check your Corners when
you enter an area if there are Bedlam
Raiders because do your thing they're
always hiding always be scanning always
be scared
always on point they're all Droid to
cause in the game you see that in one of
the trailers
hey what have you found
you want to press it right
thanks pack a punch okay now let's find
a way out of this target
so we have these things they follow us
so we can have them kind of
and then we can pick them up
that could be useful
foreign
I would say this is a regular lightsaber
the thin lightsabers are like a
like a noodle thing
oh shoot I need them to get up a little
bit closer
I I think I think the best pairing in
the game is Blaster and cross God less
stat
like once I unlocked both of those I I
kind of didn't turn back I would
sometimes
I would sometimes uh do go back to
double-sided instead of cross guard but
oh yeah and that's really cool they you
can request hints
if you need it but I'm just having a
little trouble here I just need I just
need to follow me but not get close
enough that it's gonna explode
oh no no
okay thank God
there we go
there that should do it
let's keep moving we're almost there
feeding one are you okay
thank you
shouldn't I tell you to be more careful
about who you scan
come on
should have left you in that rat tar
nest
thanks Majora's Pat again
I have played the whole game so I've
I've been playing it non-stop for like
the last week so I have a lot of kind of
uh
practice shall we say
[Music]
oh that didn't kill it
thank you
oh whoops
I did not mean to do that
[Music]
good job
nope oopsie
uh you it doesn't tell you if you're
missing boxes that is
a something you can you have to unlock
there's a hidden area one of the many
hidden areas in the game and if you go
through that and beat like the mini boss
at the end of it it will add
to the minimap like Web Box locations
are but from the jump you do not have
that
and there's a bunch of things like that
like seeing where all the seeds are and
stuff
we're just gonna we're just gonna Jimmy
this a little bit
oh actually maybe I don't need
maybe not
foreign
yes it's such a full side mission too
like one of my favorite moments in the
game
I could have sworn
uh we are playing early because we are a
really small website called Game Spot
that gets review access codes really
and makes content for review you might
not have heard of us
oh that's what I need to do I needed to
cut this
yes the story is canon
Victoria's Canon I don't think they make
Star Wars stuff anymore that isn't dead
even if we may wish that it's not okay
you're a long way from Pagano
do you think I can do that BD
humble bugling
foreign
I think we're actually about to step yes
we are
all right and this is pobo ladies and
gentlemen
not a bad change of scenery Reese's
place should be around
quite the view ain't it
that your ship came down treasure Gorge
yeah we had some uh
technical problems
probably met the Bedlam Raiders then
attacked us as soon as we landed
you're okay
what y'all doing around these parts
looking up an old friend
Greece Stratus
oh craze
oh shoot I know him I run the stables in
town my name is Mosey
Speedy one
are you cute little Droid
a friendly face
likewise
well the past seems clear from here
shouldn't get in any trouble let's go
looking for it
oh and uh say hey to domadendra when you
get in town she uh doesn't take kindly
strangers we understand
thanks for the advice Mosey bet
so this is Kobo
this is what I mean when it gives big
lands between Vibes as you can see all
those blue lights in the distance
there's one like really in the far
distance there directly out of Cal those
are the meditation points you can see oh
there's rambler's reach that's the Hub
area over to the right there's like some
other things to explore so this planet
of Kobo is staggering the amount of
things to see and do this isn't even
close this area that you're seeing in
front
like this this is just one there are
sectors around all of this too it is
huge
um not every planet is like this uh the
planets are more like the planets from
Fallen order where they're mostly linear
big open areas with some kind of like
side stuff to explore
um they made Kobo like this planet
you're gonna return back here constantly
during the story it's the planet of Kobo
is very important to The Narrative of
and it's very unique and you'll find out
why in very soon
um why it's so important uh why you'll
learn what the big thing in the sky is
where is it uh you've seen the distance
that kind of like in the sky the blue
the ball of light with the things on the
either side that's very important as
well and you're going to learn all of
that in this game
but I will leave that to you to explore
thank you so much everyone for hanging
out here for the first couple of hours
of Survivor We will have additional
Survivor content going up later today
and tomorrow some guides to kind of help
you get started what to spend perk
points on what to do first how to get
the cross guard lightsaber early things
like that so keep an eye out here on
gamespot's YouTube channel
um
or if you're on Twitch go over to our
YouTube and check it out so those are
going to be coming in the next couple of
days if you want to follow more of me uh
you can find me at great britom just
like Great Britain but with Tom at the
end great britom on every platform
Twitter everything I stream on Twitch
we're playing the Avatar Legends TT RPG
on there currently we'll be playing some
late game Survivor as well
um I've beaten the game we'll probably
maybe do some new game plus but you'll
get to see all the abilities all the
Cosmetics that you can unlock things
like that so make sure to go follow me
on Twitch you can check out the unranked
podcast that I'm a part of that
uh is very much like some giant bomb
content you guys might like uh so if
you're a big giant bomb fans go check
that out uh that has a YouTube where
there's video podcast but we're also on
any podcasting platform so that's
unranked podcast thank you so much guys
for tuning in
and enjoy